Drew and I actually had a conversation
about his experience on Piers Morgan
shows as you saw it was Interruption by
peers every second it's interesting
Pierce please let me finish are you
again you're leaving like a politician
after he had done the interview Andrew
was telling me how frustrated he was
because he thought that piece was going
to be very open-minded but he felt it
was a little bit of an ambush and that
appears was taking what he said out of
context twisting his words and so Andrew
actually told me before I went on the
show to be careful be prepared because
he's gonna really try and trick you and
make you say something that you don't
necessarily mean but that's what Pierce
does Piers wants to always have the last
word Heath is out there because this is
what mainstream media do they tend to
twist people's words they tend to change
things so that it fits their narrative
this is why people like Andrew Tate are
blowing up Jordan Peterson Joe Rogan
because people are absolutely thirsty
but uncensored and unfiltered content
through content which isn't pushing any
narratives which isn't trying to trick
people or twist words people just want
the truth censorship is Rife right now
and felt compelled to speak